[MUSIC]
You've come to a special place.
You're here at a special time.
You have a great opportunity
in front of you.
We are so excited to have you here.
[MUSIC]
Welcome to Stanford.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Is this is your first time
seeing the room?
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] Here,
you'll see the nice natural light.
There's actually a nice kitchen.
Erin, hi.
>> My God, hello.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Don't look at my room.
[MUSIC]
>> My name is Juanita Duque,
I'm from Colombia.
I cannot say, I'm so excited to meet
everybody, all the classes, everything.
>> I really like that GSB has
a strong culture of vulnerability and
being honest about who you are and
being authentic.
I think it's really easy in the business
world and the political world to have this
cookie cutter image of who you are, but at
GSB people just kind of open up about what
their story is, what they really care
about, and that's something that I'm
trying to push myself to do
over the next couple of years.
So that's why I wanted to come.
>> Overall,
I'm most excited to meet people and
make relationships that I hope
will last my whole lifetime.
>> The most exciting this for
me is to discover possibilities,
which means to really understand the full
potential of things that I can do here.
People that I can meet.
>> I think the energy.
It's like the people, the opportunities,
the excitement that everybody has.
[LAUGH]
[MUSIC]